how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk all things marvel
and
everything relating to the mcu and if
things weren't just completely
exciting this week with all the news
about spider-man 3.
we're still getting new material and
news for other shows that we are just
super excited to see in marvel's phase
four and today we have our very first
look at the first promotional images for
the falcon and the winter soldier
we also have some promotional images for
the one division series and we'll talk
about
the wrapping of filming for the falcon
and the winter soldier and when we can
expect to actually get the release
for the show as of course one division
is now coming first before the falcon
and the winter soldier and the falcon in
the winter soldier
is not coming until next year but it's
looking like we won't have to wait that
long and i'll break down everything we
know
in this video but if you're new be sure
to subscribe so you don't miss out on
any of the latest mcu news and so you
can enter this week's giveaway for a
chance to win a loki funko pop just
subscribe
like the video and leave a comment below
so today we got our very first
promotional image from marvel studios
for the falcon and the winter soldier
and it looks pretty good it's very
colorful it has the shield in the
background
but if you look to the right it actually
has the avengers logo
which is pretty interesting because we
all assume that after avengers end game
the avengers kind of disbanded for a
little bit
even an executive at disney said that we
are living in a post-avengers
world a world where the avengers aren't
really a team at the moment
and if you think about it their key
members aren't here anymore iron man is
no longer with us
black widow is no longer with us and she
was the person running the avengers
during the events of avengers in-game
during the five-year gap
and of course captain america isn't with
us because he lived the good life but
now the mantle of captain america has
been passed on to falcon or at least
will eventually be the more we get into
the show
but perhaps it's going to be up to the
falcon and the winter soldier to start
the avengers up again
because otherwise why would they put the
avengers logo on promotional art like
this
now keep in mind promotional art usually
goes on things that they're going to
sell
these go on toy packages t-shirts
banners for toy sections and etc
so these are basically going to go
everywhere before the show comes out
and they're going to have a pretty big
and noticeable avengers logo right there
on the banner
and we know that sam and bucky aren't
going anywhere even after
all episodes of the falcon in the winter
soldier air they'll be a big part of the
mcu moving forward even in the movies
and kevin feige has already confirmed
this so perhaps it's going to be these
two who actually reform
the new avengers which makes sense
falcon's going to be the new captain
america
so he could be calling the shots now the
good news is the fact that this promo
art has already surfaced means that
things are actually going pretty well
for the falcon and the winter soldier
and that production is going pretty
smoothly right now and it looks like
most of the filming for the show
has been completed except for the
filming that has to be done in prague
but it has been confirmed that the crew
for the falcon and the winter soldier
are in prague right now and it's
estimated that it'll take around 9 days
to finish
filming they were filming there before
they got shut down due to the
coronavirus
everything has been cleared for them to
go back so they're finally back and
they're going to finish up and that
should be about it for the filming of
the falcon in the winter soldier and
from there it'll go to editing and
post-production
now we know that the show isn't going to
be coming this year but the fact that it
should be done by the end of the year
and the fact that one a vision is coming
this year we can pretty much guess as to
when we're going to see this series
depending on how many episodes one
division is going to be
we could expect to get the falcon in the
winter soldier in january
or february so if one division comes in
december
we can pretty much expect to get falcon
in the winter soldier in february
so only a couple of months for one
division and only about four months for
the falcon and the winter soldier
and speaking of one division they
released promo art for the one division
series as well
now this art is kind of different but
let's face it the show is going to be
completely different than anything we've
seen before anyways
but this art actually looks like it was
drawn it doesn't look like pictures were
taken
and then they were edited it actually
looks like a hand drawing but again the
fact that we have this promotional image
means that things are going pretty well
and again disney and marvel have already
confirmed that one division
is coming this year so 2020 definitely
started off
very rocky but hopefully it will end on
a very positive note
with the one division series coming and
hopefully a falcon and the winter
soldier trailer
because as filming wraps up and the
editing process gets done and the closer
we get to that february mark of 2021
we should be getting a teaser trailer
for the falcon of the winter soldier
relatively soon
especially if you consider the fact that
we've already gotten a little bit of
teaser footage in marvel's big game tv
spot during the super bowl so i'm
assuming we'll get a trailer before the
end
of this year most likely going to come
with the one division series release
so let me know what you think about
these promotional photos and let me know
what you think about
falcon and the winter soldier going on
to be the leaders of the new avengers
leave all your thoughts in the comments
down below don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the latest mcu news for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof
you